hello again you watching the cave Early
Show she recognized me dressed like that
I recently spent 11 days as a fugitive
evading the capture of specially trained
police and intelligence officers all the
neighbors standing up to cancer I ended
up in Devon traveling by lorry to a
large bakery depot
unfortunately someone had tipped the
hunters off and they were on my tail
before that though I met a real-life
hero let's take a look weren't expecting
this today after her split from Johnny
Ches hits to lift with a lorry driver to
take her out of the West Country
in an area that's quite related or where
I could grab my bag yeah so if I can get
him to like that you will be a heroes
you weren't helping a damsel in distress
and you've got me away
here we go pinch points tell them not to
let anybody else in
you know that no creator
right stand by we're gonna update
Warburton's debt pi which is three
minute location of that depo do you
ready to copy they see here are three
five yet received game over k but far
too cocky for your own good
this is the entrance to warp ins been
mate we're chasing a fugitive she's just
coming in the back one of your lorries
can you get the gate open please thank
you
we're gonna stop by the bar let's move
female somebody somebody
I'm on the run is over new Quinn fancy
depth well you guys have been fine me
seriously 11 days is a mighty fine
achievement the Loire Drive you saw
there is Steve Locke he kept me hidden
kept the hunters at bay with his expert
handling of that vehicle and also kept
my spirits high when I was absolutely
knackered Steve's
worked for Warburton since the newt now
that death opened in devon 12 years ago
our time on the run was an unforgettable
experience delighted to say he's with me
now hello okay how lovely to see you
when you look back at that grab what do
you think
well bit of a surreal moment really you
know you you turning up at the lorry
while I was on my break and asking me to
try and get you out of corn or I've gone
more and as far away as possible yeah
when you said it was for stand up for
cancer and I know that sort of thing
touches everybody myself my dad died of
it and yeah we had that chat in the
lorry yes and so I was you know really
pleased to help you and try and get you
as far away as possible really great job
let's remind people what happened when
you when I first approached your lorry
here we go are you just about to leave
yeah you're going north
okay okay yeah what's going on I'm
fizzing
[Music]
are you you comin do you think
[Music]
what are you gonna do
do you remember that yeah they will do
the one thing I was concerned the only
thing I was worried about was you know
taking you with not having the clearance
from the depo in there so I had to ring
them up yeah and then we had to wait
about 45 minutes and you were getting
concerned that the hunters were gonna
come you know on your tail but we
finally got clearance and head office
and then away we went
I know Johnny had to spit because there
wasn't enough seats in the cab there's
only two seats yes but um so he went his
own way and then we finally got the
go-ahead didn't we yes yeah we had to go
ahead from head office and then off we
set up the motorway up towards Exeter
and then and then we got to the depo
yeah we got to the depo that you looked
in your rearview mirror we swallow we
follow hunches
yeah we saw this before the hunters
behind us at Avonmouth yeah so we come
off the motorway and we're heading
towards the depo and you said Steve
going into the fire station yeah
follow the fire engine in which which I
did and then the hunters come in behind
us yeah
guide the cab or they could they got out
the the cars and you said Steve go go go
so I went off a little maybe a bit too
sharp
brilliant maneuver let up you there was
no see what our viewers think yeah
somebody come on 5950
dice and they seem air in the bad guys
don't worry
[Music]
[Music]
we've lost mouths like beautifully so it
was a slow speed chase wasn't it in that
lorry eventually we did get corners in
the in the depo but how would you
describe your experience you've been a
bit of a superstar since well I wouldn't
call me that no I've had a lot of people
talking about it at work and things like
that and friends and that telling me you
paid you know but um no it's it's just
surreal really me being here with you in
you know thank you for the opportunity
for bringing them here
not one of your colleagues in fact I
think it was a press office who tweeted
earlier on today let's never listen to
what they had to say if I got that tweet
somewhere that I can have a look at it I
can't see it so somebody can tell me
what it says let me let me stand up and
then I can read it Steve just in case
people come the dubbing in of caber
least on Celebrity hunted by a member of
our team was a shame especially after
our lovely driver helped her for several
hours but of course the reward money
went to su TC which she stand up to
cancer as Cancer Research UK is our
charity of choice and our people have
raised one and a half million pounds and
Counting and that was one of the things
wasn't it Steve that everybody wanted to
help us in the depo because it is one of
the charities yeah yeah Warburton's
always helped the Cancer Research UK
yeah and they do a lot of stuff to
render each step around the UK
fundraising in that and like you say I
think they've raised about 1/2 million
in the three years we're doing it and
we're saying that that cancer has
affected your family as well oh yes my
dad my dad died 18 years ago of cancer
so there's about the same time as you
would get any man yes yes two years two
weeks I before I got those getting
married so yes you know never never
forget did you say yes when I came up to
the bit like I say to you know I said to
you I always watch Sky News and I enjoy
watching your program
so you know it was a pleasure for me to
take you on on the journey helping
anything to do with cancer or suppose
there's a good thing there's no when
people say oh you know that program it's
just hyped up it wasn't a toy it was
okay until we got near the end then the
adrenaline starts kicking in a bit when
the when the hunters come up the side of
you and you said to a Steve look lock
the doors
because they were try and get in front
of you to try and stop the vehicle and
yeah it was exhilarating really in the
end but it was just a shame that it
ended really the way we had and they
didn't know we don't know but in the end
I think probably I mean we've raised a
lot of money for cancer and even I don't
want you to comment on it but even that
guy who took the 500 quid for da boom in
has given it to Sundin yeah I know I
know he has given 2 quid for a new
identity especially hopefully he's
everybody it was well I suppose it is a
bit of fun isn't it yes sort of a no
better game shows when you're on the run
yeah and that's what people do they ring
up and say they've spotted people so it
was disappointing but hey it's all ended
up well it's all ended up well off and I
got to meet you and I've got to meet you
thank you